Hello, Joseph, how are you?
Hey, how you doing?
Doing well. How are things over there?
Hanging in there, went from 100 degree weather to about 70 degrees, so that's a 30 degree drop right there. Gotta adjust, gotta readjust.
Okay, good.
Uh-huh, right.
How about you guys?
Rains have started, monsoon have started. These are the months when we have a lot of rain in India. So entire India is getting rain right now. So from very hot to a bit lesser hot now.
Good.
Hello, Andrea.
Thank you.
Hey Andy, hi Joe. Sorry I'm late. I just got off of a meeting. How are you guys?
Good, good.
All right. Hey, Natalie.
Hey, hey, how's everyone doing?
S.
And Joseph, just to introduce myself, I am from the customer experience team from Natalie team.
Pleasure to meet you. I think it's our first time meeting Andy. I know I've met Natalie before.
Yeah.
Yep, so Andy's going to just help me out on the customer experience side. So you'll see a little bit more of him, but don't worry, I'll still be around too.
Sounds good. Team work.
There you go.
All right, so you only see me, unfortunately, on the surface of the re side because Marky is out today. He will be attending a leadership training for Writing by Design tomorrow, which is why, unfortunately, Joe, you're stuck with myself. So I'll share. Yeah, that's unfortunate.
Yeah.
Cool.
The.
Yes.
Yeah, sorry about that, Joe.
Yeah.
Alright, I'll share my screen.
Always love working with you, Andy, so no worries.
Alrighty, can you guys see my screen?
Yep.
All right, so this is going to be our monthly business review. This is for the month of June.
Moving on, so why is it not working? There we go. So same agenda, Joe. Check in highlights, action tracker, performance, KPI, way forward, and of course, our recap. So wanted to highlight a few things for Jacob, still consistent on perfect attendance.
So we had no issues ever with Jacob's attendance, which is wanted to highlight. And we also wanted to mention that MCG has now an escalation matrix, which actually helped him align with the ticket flow and prioritization. I know that there was an issue in the past about, you know, when to escalate tickets, and this is something that you also work with.
with Marky on. So that has been sorted out, which is appreciate your help there. So Jacob has mentioned during their one-on-one with Marky that it actually helped him a lot when it comes to the tickets of these handling. So that will be our highlights for June.
Awesome.
Any questions?
Okay.
All right, action tracker. So we recently sent out the monthly feedback for Jacob. I think you completed that, didn't you?
No, I did see it. I don't think I completed it. I don't think I completed it. So I will, I did flag it because it comes in as a blue category for me. So I'll go ahead and get that done, you know, shortly after this call.
Mhm.
All right, perfect. Thank you very much.
Okay, moving on to performance analysis. So we start, let's start with utilization and trend analysis for Jacob. So the data shows the four week period that he has for June. So we have 20, 24%. This is the billable utilization. And it increased during the first few weeks, reaching a peak of 30% in week three.
It kind of dipped on June due to the PTO use for the month, but we wanted to make sure that we keep up with the 80% target for him. And if I'm not mistaken, he's been doing a lot of project work, right?
Yep.
Yeah, there is some work that he's been, you know, for projects for like Intune migration for some of our clients, so yeah, he, yeah, he's been, we've been shifting him around to, you know, a couple other projects we may have as well.
Mhm, mhm.
Gotcha. Do you guys have like project tickets for those respective tasks for him?
They should be, there would be tasks instead of tickets within auto task. I would have to double check. So, you know, and in this part, you know, we may have to come back to this, but the tasks, the tasks are now assigned by me specifically. They're assigned either by the project manager or the account manager, depending on who's, you know, working on the project.
Mm.
Mhm.
So that's why I said I have to probably get back to you on that.
Sure, that's completely fine. The reason why I'm asking is because there are certain things that he does that maybe is not being captured on the ticket or maybe by a task it's not captured. So it's not putting a lot of numbers on the utilization, which is what we're seeing right now, because I know that he's doing a lot of things in a daily basis. However,
It looks like when it comes to the billable, of course, that will be the reactive ticket that he works with your end users, right? However, for the project, I think it's internal. That's why it's not adding hours into it. But if you want, I can work with Jacob Mark and I can actually work with Jacob so that we can track that.
Kour.
What I usually ask some of the engineers is to create their internal ticket so that they can track some of the things in there so that it can actually put their billable or non-billable utilization into one ticket only.
That's fine. I think maybe we need to have a conversation afterwards. I just, I'm curious to also take a look at the data and just correlate, you know, which ones are potential projects that are not appearing as part of this build utilization. I will be, I will say that June also tends to be a little bit more of a dip.
Mhm.
in terms of overall tickets. I mean, our overall ticket count was about, you know, 100 to 150 less overall. So it's usually it's a little bit more of a sore month. Graduations are happening. We have a couple of holidays, such as 4th of July. So there's a lot, you know.
Yeah, true.
Not happening usually in the month of June, so I usually expect a little bit more of a dip.
Gotcha. Yeah, we can regroup and probably talk about that more. Okay.
Sure.
Alrighty, let's move on to ticket closure trends. So ticket closure, he has an average of 76.8 resolution. Week one, he has like 90 tickets, close 73. Same with week two, he got 44. As you can see, just like what he mentioned, there's a dip with the tickets in there.
And week three, he has like 59, we saw 35. And for the week 4, which shows the utilization earlier, 34 tickets in close 28. So average resolution rate for this is 76.8, but remained consistent above the 80% in weeks one and second.
Gotcha. OK.
Any questions?
No, the only, I guess the only one, we're probably we're tracking this manually, so maybe a separate conversation as well, is just the number of tickets that Jacob would mark as an escalation. I don't think I see that here. I don't know if that maybe it's on your next slide, but I thought it would be part of this.
Mhm.
Yeah, we should be adding that. I don't think it's part of the slide just yet. We can, I can work with Marky and Jacob. Maybe we can use also auto task. I think we had a bit of a conversation when it comes to that escalation that we're tracking manually.
Okay.
and what constitute is an escalation, right? So...
Correct. Yeah, no, I know where there's a manual process that we probably would have to take. And to that point, we are working on a, you know, on a new agent, which may be able to get that data for us, which hopefully simplify that process as well.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Okay, I gotcha. Oh, how about the BrightGauge creation of dashboard that we had a discussion before? Has it been created? Do you need any help with that?
Yes.
That.
I would say we probably need to schedule a different time for the creation of it. What's, there's just a lot going on right now. A lot of people are also on vacation at the moment, so we're kind of a little tight on resources. So it's been, it's still on my list of items that I need to work on, but it's this, for example, this new agent.
Mhm.
Okay.
Taking the priority just 'cause it's a trial base right now, so we have to try and, you know, get as much done within it, um, you know, to see if it's something we're gonna deploy consistently after, you know, trial.
Mhm.
Push for it. Yeah.
Sure.
I gotcha, no problem. All right, so probably mid, I don't know, whenever you're free July, so that we can actually, it probably include the escalation rate for Jacob, so that we can we can add that to the slides and see how he's doing when it comes to those type of tickets.
But for the meantime, what I can do is I'll work manually with Marky and Jacob to actually get that for you. Okay.
Sounds good, thank you.
No problem.
Alrighty. Okay, so for way forward certification for Azure, we already had a schedule for him. So this should be July. Before end of July, she should or he should be able to take that certification for the for Azure. And then we wanted to make sure that he continue.
the progress, this is for us leadership, the BrightKate discussion, which we already talked about. And Jacob will own the security awareness training and provide reports to responsible personnel. Is this something that you talk to Marky about or Jacob about the awareness training?
So we actually spoke to him when he came back from his vacation as well, just to kind of follow up with him. I think he has the process down. It's more of the remaining, I guess, you know, part where he still needs just a little bit of training on or assistance on is just the drafting to the client itself.
Mhm.
Uh.
That part is that part is still very custom per client. It's not just like we take it from straight from no before or straight from Huntress. We drafted based on previous information that we've had and there is a guide in process that Joe Gonzalez, which is the engineer has been working with.
Jacob to transition into that has, you know, he's been providing this information for. He's also still working with him. So we still have, I believe, this month and next month to kind of, you know, work with Jacob, try to make sure that he is comfortable before he fully owns it by himself. So he still has Joe G for reference. And even after that, if he would need a hand in.
Mm.
Transition.
determining, hey, you know, what's the approach with the customer based on what I'm seeing, he could still reach out to Joe G. But at this point, Jacob is owning the process from beginning, pretty much till end. He just, I think he just reviews with Joe G on the wording of the e-mail to the customer, pretty much.
Uh-huh.
Mm.
Okay, kind of like double checking everything before we send it out to the customer.
Yeah, yeah, not everything. I think it's more based on where he's not maybe not comfortable. For example, Huntress, I think it's a little bit easier, but NoB4 can be a little bit more detailed. So that may be somewhere where he reaches out to Joe G for specifics on. So my feedback from Joe G, our engineer, is that he's been doing pretty well.
Mm.
And that, you know, basically it's just, you know, touch up on a couple of things, you know, before sending it out.
Okay, gotcha. No problem. So if the process is there, I think Jacob is already familiar with it and he has like, just like what he mentioned, I think this quarter to transition fully to that role and own it, own the responsibility.
Kip.
100%. I do want to touch base on the Azure. So I'm not aware of which certification he's taking in specifically. So I would be curious if you could send me the certificate name that he's going to be addressing or taking. Generally speaking, sorry, go ahead.
Oh.
Hello?
Mhm.
I think it's...
Yeah, I think it's AZ 900, if I'm not mistaken.
See, just write that down here.
Yeah.
C900.
OK, alright.
I think this is based off of the catch up that we had in the past. This is part of his CDP as well to like add more skill set into what he's currently doing.
Yeah, no, absolutely. And I would actually love it for him to take on a little bit more because we are dealing with more AVD infrastructure for our clients. So I would be interested in aligning what he's going to be taking along with what some of our engineers are actually working on. So to that point, I just want to confirm that it's the AZ900 that we're taking. If not, I'm not that
Mhm.
Okay.
I have to say to stop that certification. If that's something Jacob wants to take, absolutely, to go out and take it. I just know that if it's a certification that we're also looking to achieve, that we would also pay for it same way that we did for the last one. And that's what I want to make him aware of, to remind him that if it's aligned with what we're also looking for, then we would absolutely pay for that certification for him to take it.
Yeah.
So, I'll double check on that with our team, and if it matches, then you know we'll reach out to Jacob to make sure he knows that, you know, same as last time, we'll pay for the certification for him to to take to take the exam.
Definitely.
Gotcha. Same process as before, like for example, it matches with, you know, the needs of the company, especially you guys on that side of the fence. Once he passes it, then that's the only time that you pay for it. But if he doesn't, which I don't think he will plug in, but just in case it doesn't, then you don't have to pay for that. So that's the process for IT by design.
So...
Oh, okay. I was not aware of that. That's interesting. Okay, so that, okay, so then the last time when we did it, we actually paid for his certification. I, again, wasn't aware of it, so now I know we'll go through you guys then 1st to make you aware of which certification we're looking for.
And.
Yes.
Yeah.
And then, so when he passes at that point, we would pay for it, you said? Okay.
That's when you get, yeah, so that's the only time that you get an invoice and then you pay for, so that we can reimburse him for what he shelled out for that certification.
Gotcha, and okay, and then just to confirm, because, like I said, what we handled before, we paid for it directly, that that cannot be done right. It has to be done through this process here. Okay, okay, I was not aware of that. Okay, I'll discuss with my team then. So then, just in that in that same process, yes, we want him to go for certifications.
Mhm.
Yes, yeah.
But then we probably want to just have a conversation about which certification he's taking, so that way we can align to make sure it's, you know, what MCG is also looking for, you know, before moving forward.
Sure.
Definitely. So probably just let me know once you get it checked on your side of things. And then I'll give them a heads up, maybe before taking and scheduling it for July. Okay.
Okay.
Sounds perfect. Thank you, Andrea, or Andy.
You're very much welcome. All right, let's see. Bill it live. As you mentioned, you weren't able to come because of several reasons. Currently, we understand that, but do you think that you can send someone else? I know, shooting my shot here, Natalie.
Yeah, it's me.
No, Andy, I appreciate it. I think, you know, we have a couple of things lined up for this, the remaining part of the summer. Like I said, we're taking on Neo Agent and a couple other tools. You know, possible transition from Threat Locker as well, so it's just...
Mhm.
Yeah.
We got a lot lined up, which is why I didn't want to say yes, then come back to say no. I'd rather say, you know, I don't think at this time it's going to make sense. Me personally, I'm hoping that, you know, once we have a lot of these tools in place, that I will have the ability to go to some of these and potentially take an engineer with me, or maybe somebody from our Helpdesk come along. That's my like long-term goal.
There's just a lot happening on the back end right now that doesn't make this feasible. But definitely keep me in mind for the next event. And again, if it hopefully will, things will be dying down a little bit more in terms of app transition and stuff like that. And then I can look to either at least going myself or potentially taking myself and an engineer to some of these events.
Sure. I think the next one after Boldit is, do we have an AI mastermind again, Natalie?
Yeah, we'll be doing like quarterly events. Yeah, Joseph, the only reason I would push a little harder to have somebody come is because the AI accelerator is included. So as you guys are working towards how to actually drive revenue and then even just the different tools
that are out there in education on AI, that's a good person to send to this event if they're available to come. Otherwise, I'll just keep you in mind. We have a lot of community activities and we'll just make sure that we're letting you know when those are happening. So you can just get more engaged with the community overall and our other partners.
Sounds good. Thank you.
Alrighty.
And I think, yeah, that's pretty much it. I'll stop sharing now. All right, do you guys have any questions? Wanted to talk about anything at all?
No, I think I think you did a great job, Andy, as usual, thank you so much for your time and dedication to our account. We really appreciate it.
Joe.
Very much welcome. I hope I get I did make Marky proud today. All right. Natalie, Andy, anything to add?
I'm all good on my side. Thank you.
All good. Thank you. Nice meeting you, Joseph.
Nice to meet you too, Andy.
All right. If that's it, thank you very much. Thanks, Joe. Have a good day. Hope to see you soon. Bye.
Take care, guys. Bye-bye.